PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome
to Deconstructing Chatbots.
I am Priyanka Vergadia,
and in this episode,
we are going to build
our first chatbot.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Like a promise, we are
going to jump right
into the Dialogflow interface.
Navigate to console to
Dialogflow.com and sign in.
If you're a first time user,
then just use your email
to sign up.
Accept all the terms
and conditions,
and you'll be in the console.
Now, create new agent.
Let's call this
appointment scheduler.
Dialogflow creates a
GCP project for you
to access logs and
Cloud functions.
You can select an
existing project as well.
Then, just create.
You get two default intents
as a part of your agent.
The default welcome intent
helps greet your users.
And the default fallback intent
helps catch all the questions
that your bot does
not understand.
At this point, you
have a functional bot.
All it does is greet the users.
Well, let's test it.
If we say hi, our
bot responds back
with a hi, and a how
I can help message.
Once you ask for help, such
as, set an appointment,
it does not know what to do.
So it kicks in the
fallback intent,
obviously because we've
not created any intent
to catch that
particular request.
So let's add that now.
Let's create a new intent and
call it schedule appointment.
We will skip context
and events for now.
Let's get down to
the training phrases
and add some phrases here.
As you're putting
these in, you will
see date and time are
automatically identified
as system entity date and time.
Now, to make this
functional, we need
to respond back to the user.
So let's add a response.
You could just say, you're
all set, see you then.
Or you could make it a little
bit more interesting and say,
you're all set for this
date and this time.
See you then.
The dollar sign here helps
you access the entity values.
Let's test it with, set
an appointment for 4:00
PM on Thursday.
And as expected, you
get the right response
with the right date and time.
Now, what if somebody just
said, set an appointment?
Well, that is not
really specific,
and we have not yet handled
that scenario in our bot.
To support this, we use
something called slot filling.
We make the entities
as required,
and Dialogflow will make sure
to ask for both date and time
before it responds back.
Let's add, what
time would you like
to come in, for the time
prompt, and what date,
for the date prompt.
You can add other variants,
too, and then just save.
OK, let's test one more time
to see if things are working.
Let's say, set an appointment.
Our bot responds with, what
time would you like to come in?
And I say, 10:00 AM.
And then it asks for the
date, and I say February 12.
All right, got all that.
It's all working.
OK, so all the testing we did so
far has been in the simulator.
But what if you wanted to
share this win with a friend?
Let's go into integration
and enable the web demo.
And just like that, you
have a link to your bot
that you can share or a
iFrame into your website
or mobile application.
You can test to see
if it's working.
All right, so today we set up
a simple appointment scheduler
that takes date and
time as input variables,
and responds back to the
user with an appointment
confirmation.
We also learned
about slot filling.
If a user only provided us with
a date, or time, or nothing,
how you can prompt the user to
provide the missing information
seamlessly.
And finally, we learned how to
test our bot in the simulator
and integrated it
into a website.
Don't miss the next episode
of Deconstructing Chatbots
because we are going
to make our appointment
scheduler a little bit smarter.
[MUSIC PLAYING]